everybody excellent
welcome to returning councillors and
welcome to new elected members to the
Annual General Meeting and also welcome
to the public is the chief executive
council the meeting and start with the
first item which is the election chair
of the council but I invite nominations
for the position of chair of the Capitol
Thank You chief executive I've known
councillor Huckabee for number of years
as a fellow justice on the northeast
armature and dales magistrates bench she
served on the bench from of 20 years and
there's a reputation as someone with
sound judgment and reliability you know
the dedication to the local community is
something very close to her heart
Carol Huckabee has been a parish
councillor for 32 years
she's a member of three local charitable
trusts which on the home field
Educational Foundation the post feel
relief in me and the Holmes field
amenity trust each of these for no less
than 24 years Council Huckabee so for
several years as a governor of penny
acres and Henry Fanshawe scores in 1998
she was elected to know these dogs she
district council as a member for the
award of barlow and Holmes field since
being elected council hooker vada served
on many committees including planning
and licensing all of this experience
will have given her a good grounding for
the role she's to undertake she is
married to Stuart who I am sure will be
unable consult and I believe that both
will represent the district well in a
civic capacity as such I propose
councillor Carol Huckabee for chair of
northeast or district
Council for the Civic year 2019 2020
Thank You Council second do you have a
seconder thank you
I'm absolutely delighted to second Carol
Kirby for the position of chair of the
council as council a factor has said her
husband Stewart's that will be her
consort and I know you'll do an
excellent job in supporting Carol to
represent our great district Stewart had
a long career in high-speed packaging
with a particular focus on materials and
engineering he started his career in an
American multi-national or going on to
become a commercial deaf director at
elite Facebook for 17 years he then
spent time in London Sweden wayward
European coordinator for a large
Scandinavian company for the last 50
years he's worked with very fast
multinational companies as a packaging
consultant he's been happily married to
Carol for 43 years
can I thank Stewart's on behalf of the
capital in advance for the fantastic
support that I know he will offer a new
chair buzz again I'm very happy to echo
and council backers words and second
Carol luckily for the position of chair
of the council thank you can sit there
are there any other nominations okay all
those in favor of council Huckabay
please hold those against ordering
abstentions
thank you council the caravel committees
there for Julie elected as the chair of
Council
sign the Declaration and receive the
chit chat chains
[Music]
I nominate counselor packed and equip my
second counselor personally any further
nominations all those in favor
okay again so any other against and up
sections
thank you I am therefore
delighted to announce that councillor
passengers is Juliana
apologies for absence Thank You chairman
I'm like apologies in advance are there
any more canceled in its is everybody
happy to sign the minutes to confirm
that they are a correct record found so
this is to discuss the minutes they can
only Chinese their accuracy they are not
pointing about anything wrong or missing
then we can stop them and stop them and
the myths are honored to be fulfilled as
a political movement chef second
objection
before my announcement I would just like
to say that although the council thank
you chair to have with me the words from
councillor Ridgeway can I first give my
apologies for not being with you all
today I can assure you I would rather be
in the chamber than where I am at this
very moment let me say it's been a
wonderful year and I have been very
proud to represent North East Derbyshire
as chair of the council we have made
many friends over the last 12 months and
relish the opportunity to raise money
for my charity to support the excellent
mental health services provided by a
Chesterfield Royal Hospital over the
year we have raised 4,500 pounds which
will go a long way towards buying a
distraction unit to help treat dementia
patients at the hospital I must thank
Glyn wildmen for his attention and
support on behalf of the hospital and
who I know is with you today you will
all be aware it takes a team of people
to organize and make a chairs year
successful so there are a number of
facts to be mentioned firstly thank you
to the entire council for giving me the
opportunity to represent the people of
North East Derbyshire in such a
high-profile way second there is a whole
team who I would like to thank who are
consistent reliable and fully supportive
of the chairs position in particular
Allen mom Nicola Carver and Donna cans
and Gordon services as well as the
chauffeur
David and Octavian who have seen it all
before
they are full of little generals with
tips and tricks for each occasion my
thanks also go out to the other team of
people who I have relied on for the last
12 months not least of whom is Bryan my
husband and consort who has been with me
for many of these events even if he was
uncomfortable being chauffeured driven
my apologies if I have missed anyone
else but I have appreciated everyone's
input in this period we have tried to be
a little different this year so my
thanks to speak hell school and the head
teacher for hosting my auction Edgington
Parish Council did us proud for the
Civic service as my home parish I was
especially pleased to hold the event
there clay cross members what's a
wonderful noise of music and dance you
worked so hard and gave us a night to
remember
Pilon collar Evander speedrun rules was
a brilliant night of bone music and
hospitality thank you to Council thank
you for the invitation for that evening
drop vo brass band competition is always
special and this year was no different
every event that we attended this year
was very memorable and northeast
overture and ourselves made many friends
finally can I personally thank all
counselors across the table for their
support and contributions I am proud to
be counted among your number the things
have gone to clone the council that has
been kind enough to read my words and I
also take the time to thank him not just
for this but for the support he has
given me there is a chance a rich way
and I believe this council should note
the excellent way in which councillor
Ridgeway has carried out her duties
along with the support of Bryan as her
consort council rich Ramos chaired meet
for council effectively and represented
this district in a positive manner it
should be recorded that the best thanks
of this council be accorded to
councillor Jackie Ridgeway and Brian
Ridgeway for their time in office I
don't have any announcements to make
yes although I am pleased to report the
time attending the investiture of the
Bishop of Derby on Saturday what I'd
like to do is to present a rather big
check now to gain Wildmon on
Chesterfield Royal Hospital which
councillor Ridgeway raised during that
an office which was 4,500 pounds
[Music]
[Applause]
I give you an undertaking to be a fair
and even a little chair and hopefully
over the coming months you will see that
my actions match my words
I also promise to serve the council in
my home a sartorial role to the best of
my ability northeast Iowa State is a
great place and is a great place to live
Michael needs to be the first citizen
through a large district and to speak
for all of North East dog show
[Applause]
Thank You chair so I'd like to propose
my colleague and friend counselor Martin
Bucer
MBE to the position of leader and the
council's Barton has been a district
councillor representing Bronx and Walton
Ward since 2007 prior to that he was a
borough councillor in Chesterfield from
1991 to 1995 he served eight years as
leader of the conservative group on this
council before leading us to a historic
victory earlier this month I'm bringing
to power the first conservative
administration ever to run this council
in his working life Martin has been a
teacher and a head teacher for many
years
and Natalie has been working for the
National deaf children Society as a
strong and passionate champion for some
of the most vulnerable children in
society it is spare time martin supports
a wide range of local community and
civic organizations and charities these
charities local parish council and is a
hard-working and dedicated local
councillor for his constituents I know
Martin have all the skills and
experience to make an excellent leader
of this council they will help to bring
about a new door for Northeast our
worship thank you Thank You chairman
welcome to your new role do a fantastic
job of the District Council it's my
great pleasure to second nomination for
councillor Martin Thakur I know Martin
a good number years now and there is a
family connection in fact my father knew
his father and brother they went to
something difficult in Darby so one of
the key things I do know about Martin
particularly his his great involvement
in the civic life of the district and
Derbyshire and there's a great champion
try for a philosophy courses as
councillor David already said and what I
knew in particularly for his work with
the deaf community which is the reason
why is to so it is my pleasure to second
that nomination the house helps did it
run quite an extraordinary results I
think the northeast auction and absolute
first and having a conservative America
administrations
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to announce the names which
you can see on the screen and just to
put a context to the cabinet portfolios
there's the intention of the
conservative administration over the
next twelve months to carry out various
manifesto pledges first of all we will
intend to pause the local plant to
enable a full review to consider our
options and carrying out a listening
exercise we are clay in our ambition to
protect the Greenbelt and reduce the
overall housing requirement to a more
sustainable level we'll be carrying out
a line-by-line budget review to ensure
that council is spending residents money
wisely and to help us prepare for a
council tax freeze next year you'll also
be commencing an immediate review of
parking issues across the district as
well as a wide-ranging review of
planning licensing and environmental
health enforcement to ensure that we are
doing everything we can to actively
discourage breaches and take necessary
legal steps where necessary we'll be
introducing measures to improve the
transparency and accessibility of
council meetings including audio-visual
recordings of meetings starting today
we'll also be signing the British sign
language
to enhance support for deaf residents of
this district we'll be exploring a range
of other options to improve the way we
engage with residents and communities so
that we truly become a listening council
we will be supporting veterans by
reciting as a new administration the
Armed Forces covenant will be developing
our policies to ensure we are doing our
bit to help reduce emissions and respond
to the challenges of climate change we
will be developing a new public facing
council plan to replace the old
corporate plan which will help to
deliver our manifesto commitments in
full as such I moved all the named
councillors on my cabinet portfolios
list as on the street yeah thank you
congratulations on your new post and I'm
sure you'll do a great job I shall be
moving any alternative cabinet obviously
well I'll just make the point that is
obviously one extra cabinet position and
what we are which which adds an extra
thousand three eleven pounds fourteen
pence to the overall bill which seems a
good start in trying to achieve what an
out million pound where the savings of
which you've got achieve over the next
two years so I wish you well with that a
nice speech Martin they were locked in
that and I had told some of the things
I'm disappointed you've stopped the
local plan well pause me we still come
up to time and effort was respond
competitive near the gate as far as we
have to pause it is just don't you know
the the chances for developers to take
on board all the tests and developing it
in all the breeding fields in this part
of the district so I wish you well with
all that but we won't be out the way yet
we won't be offering up a covenant
yes points of explanation where counsel
vodka I thought you went to second all
my cabinet nominations they're there
just to point out that if you look back
at previous cabinet positions you
actually had more it's only in recent
years you've produced even wonder
whether it was because you couldn't find
anybody or not I'm not sure you have
what I want I want to make it very clear
so we're not adding additional eight and
a half thousand pounds the actual
cabinet positions will be in the same
envelope of costings
and we've already committed to that and
discuss that with the chief executive
you'll also notice that with chairs and
vice chairs that will also double up on
some which also affords a saving so
we're actually reducing the amount that
you've spent in your labor
administration maybe's get your facts
right before you start accusing me of
anything else but I do thank you for
your positive comments about what we
intend to deliver the local plan you've
always known our views on it and we're
happy to work with your group to discuss
any aspect of it this is a listening
yes they did the privileges for the
leaders to assign those agenda is mine
which is a point of view it sets how the
review of the Constitution this reviews
that - my son sweetie open senior year
we received 13 a number of areas have
been reviewed and these are set out at
one point five in the report in front of
you
this includes revision of the members
credit conduct inclusion of a social
media policy members and a change to the
establishment of the licensed intimacy
in line with the council's legal
obligations each change is detailed in
the appendices including the rationale
that any amendments made the
recommendations are that the amendments
are approved and the monitoring officer
can be delegated power to make
amendments arising new legislation and
the initiative errors that revise or
conflicts in interpretation
- group I rule conservative nomination
[Applause]
No than share if I just walk is
accommodating well between labor group
tire company on block all the chairs of
my chairs has put forward by ourselves I
do want to say that I am disappointed at
Labor's of children to reject the vice
chairs that have been offered we were in
opposition for eight years when we were
given nothing by the laser group thank
you so this was an olive branch that has
been offered to you and it might have
not been the committee's you wanted on
this occasion but it was a start and I
think it could have been something
different for the year after next and so
on in the first year and you were
offered an olive branch but instead
you've chosen to snap that branch in
half throw it back in our faces and
trumple all over it I'm really
disappointed it's not a positive
indication of how we want to work going
forward and as a new start to this
council and I'm disappointed for the
residents of Northeast our worship so
you've chosen to reject that olive
branch yeah yes might be ahead we get
the way macGruber appreciated the offer
of the deal vice-chairs
but we made the decision they really
well it's not well you only election
fair and square we we tap that on the
chin and congratulations to the year to
their members that avert that are there
and that have come along this time and
the ones that have been reelected and if
your ways for them
the
that didn't get elected at the last
election and hopefully now the new
members
yo man first and our difficult it is to
carry on providing excellent services
vigor a central government is determined
to slash local rule and spending and
really wants to undermine local
government that have returned
it's not easy as you'll find out so
hopefully that's right and like I was
saying
agonal felt equal rights and profits
then you have all the spoils and also we
didn't want to be associated with things
when he starts going belly-up so that
mass and that was up that's our decision
and again so we won't be nominated to
our cheers with all the tones
nominations will be councilors Cupit
bail and power but I'm able to inform
the council of our cocoon are
relinquishing your that place on little
more things you don't want to be
associated with us
belly up according to you and are you
turning down the outside bodies that
we've offered to you
I like nominate I feel so young just
don't ignore me so I think it's
appropriate that Betty's been involved
from day one and she's allowed to stay
on because over there deal offices all
so our they grew up in the
recommendation for ignored is Betty hill
and I'm sorry we're not - well the isn't
it things more now me and Jolin
what would say well I just spend an
afternoon talking with you don't think
that's not for this Tracy but we can
definitely nominate to those positions
and play just bow in German on gave a
video and play I will let will face some
things thank you
please disco fire because we've now had
an additional one for equal we've been
up at three places there is a fourth one
it's three places today again we thought
this discussion tells the market so it
now you're throwing something in the mix
so I want to confirm that the three
places today on the conservative
nomination and we'll come back to the
fourth position in due course
funky check yeah I won't just speak
about written or more than anything I
just think I was there at the very
beginning it was me the name actually
and I was there when they said we've got
to form an Elmo and I've been there
right through for the last 10 years
get informative and stuck in them and
supporting them and if at all possible
I'm not pleading for some much-needed so
did you know nothing but if at all
possible I would like to remain on that
so there's no doubt about your
dedication counsel no doubt whatsoever
today just just agreeing the three
places people say to one the other in
old place which is the Labour one it's
something that the group isn't so but
that is sympathetic to so where you
don't need to be a miserable creature to
them
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] I fight you have the purposes of
the record it is as per the list the
three representatives to the ripple
board for the conservative approve the
issue of counselor denomination will be
leveled at a later stage
and within that list there is a gap for
the Danes poor job in Joel bloom so
unless I'm sensing some resistance to
that being three Labour councillors
there'll be three labor positions
dominated and you're confirmed to be
writing in those people yet don't know
yesterday you could get to that we have
a second nurse a lot been the point but
to or as her paper as per the discussion
asked there about of I'm sure okay is it
out really to clarify so if we agree the
political elements of those positions
but not necessarily the names will say
those into course yeah okay thank you
only all those in favor against all
those in favor
under the monitor
Thank You chair the report sets out the
definition of the human this report is
before you to advise you of occasions
and it is not be possible to give the
full 28 days Lovick notice four key
decisions this is a requirement
contained in the regulations outlined in
the report as you can see from the
report there are limits for such
occasions it is also a requirement to
report a number of callings over the
previous 12 months and again there have
been none the final part of the report
is seeking confirmation of the financial
those materials that is a hundred
thousand pounds of Revenue matters and
250 thousand pounds of capital matters
all those in favor all those against any
expensive
I cancelled their orbital to absorb the
pro sale of the green building for the
north and west of the populace Rose also
to a fair result on place and
investigators believe inconsistent with
in
obviously it's a step as a council we
need to establish in the phone booths
for a decision from the other day we
need to move the tables that this motion
goes beyond that what meditates to use
the word predetermination what I suspect
note their microphone watch our session
while at the minutes without reaching
that conclusion the pauline committee
were misled report from highway state
and as a minimum visibilities 95 cases
from the junction was neither which was
this was presented to the committee as
these easy stating was
visibility existed despite evidence be
preserved to the center and in TCC's
have report as a large initiative
knowledge this misrepresentation was
asserted to the committee bargain
offices on the ranchera Planning Council
rich face amendment though the junction
between combine in the new development
should not be opened until worse were
complete which was accepted by the
members of that committee was then
retrospectively changed to over the
junction was the first residents lived
in that was not what the committee
members voted on and why except to make
sure the whole sector divided the
integrity of probity needed in any
planning process and so on the report
report independent investigation to
inspire that day finally as council
shipment touched on we have the question
of the decision by Council for a
commercial loan of millions of pounds of
council tax payers money secured online
already over by the council to the
company we're never trading history
whatsoever I spent quite a few years as
an underwriter will absolutely prevent
such a proposal there is nothing in
principle one that probably not making a
commercial business decisions where they
need to be signed your based and subject
to the proper scrutiny the one would
expect from any commercial under so I
urge all sides of this change about the
notion is entirety and I've got on
record with this men of the court for
recorded vote are there any more members
wishing to speak
thank you
I think to an assistant these reports
say new words it's a matter of public
record that the conservative group
proposed proposals at a meeting of the
full council the development of land at
the north and west of the poplars and
Kemal Road
therefore initial objections from
elected elected members came from
conservatives and one or two others from
the labor group at the time we outlined
several concerns based on the report
provided to Council which in our opinion
did not provide sufficient information
but what I'm concerned about in the
wording of this motion is statement of
fact that there are inconsistencies with
regard to planning approval there are
also other assumptions made that are not
factored by concrete evidence and these
are serious the conservative group
believes an urgent review should be
carried out in order to ascertain how
far proposals for the site have gone
what the financial implications are
including potential impact on council
taxpayers of the district as well as the
residents of Taunton and on the
allegations made by the Liberal
Democrats this includes an independent
investigation the information would be
shared in the first instance with
elected members of took to Ward in order
to make clear that serious allegations
are being made by the Liberal Democrats
I wish to propose amendments to this
motion first the wording about
complaints be replaced with objections
to reflect comments made in council
debate as well as those during the
planning process to protect you I think
we should have the word alleged before
what inconsistencies in the first and
last paragraph
me too with being bothered we change the
wedding's of the third paragraph state
it is the belief of Liberal Democrats
about the decision at this stage since
no review has taken place and therefore
Council cannot take an informed view the
final paragraph calls for an immediate
review rather than withdrawal and this
is for the simple reason the council has
not yet ascertain the financial and
legal implications or additional
considerations of an immediate
withdrawal so can ask for the amendments
to be put on the screen so you can see
the wording and is there I move the
amendment
[Music]
we are we are now the amendment and we
had a proposal a seconder for that so is
there anybody else wants you to speak
the chair could move to the vote before
moving to the vote on the amendment
counselor faculty provides a reply
immediately before counselor
jintan without the drive to reply as the
proposal is how the rules work obviously
wait way forward in a bond really
because obviously when we were in power
resettled the North wood grill we went
through all the due diligence regarding
anchor ball and to be honest that women
speaking at sea because I'd like to say
some other way in without me to do a
sort a bit bit strong about the planning
committee and I thought we've done a
Annie Taylor review of that and found
that the process were farming and to be
honest looking at that you know can be
had to do quite well I tend to think
you're in power now you're in jobs to
have a look at it again and I'm not
because otherwise I'm tired offense so
thank you
just to actually of my thanks to support
the council backers go forward I would
prefer that we kept the word withdrawal
rather than with you but I'm happy to
concede that the general spirit
yes chair I like to support the
amendment
it's been a long route we've done due
diligence we've looked at developments
by the people at our book Northwood
we've seen the quality we've seen the
aesthetic design and we've seen that it
would have provided more homes that are
avoidable they've worked with people at
Cresswell that worked with people at
Howarth
and worked with people are dead we still
the time it seemed a viable proposition
and I'm sure when you look at it in
detail
it will see continue to see a viable
proposition it was a chance to use our
land as collateral and also to take
share in the profits of the end of it
well you're looking to review it not
quite happy to do that
thank you Jeff I think it's very
encouraging to have this new dawn of
everyone agreed yesterday I'll make a
note in my day when I get in there so
we've gone from the leader of the Labour
Party thank you as well Jeremy Corbyn
now Pontius Pilate because you seem to
be washing your hands and everything the
previous administration is doing and
saying that I'm happy for you to take it
forward your wills will take in the
spirit it was men counselor vodka and
cows to carry I think obviously here
you're maintaining it was a viable
proposition then you know what I said at
the time when that report came to
council my abuse will stand and so I
thank councillor Hancock for actually
accepting this amendment as a way of
actually moving forward and
promise you there will be discussion
with you in due course that when
information comes to hand
so no more rather than that chair yeah
thank you that nothing will happen to
that side prior to the output of this
review or are you saying that I don't
mention cast iron in case people
thinking I'm trying to destroy that
industry as well the thing is obviously
we've set today the fact we will do a
review so nothing else will happen now
until that review takes place and as
promised you already and I promise
Council I haven't talked in a previous
conversation we are willing to talk with
you and sit down and look at all the
proposals if it means then nothing
happens it means nothing happens it
means that we've gone too far down the
road and that's where we have to meet
that's where we have to be all the
investigation and everything else that
we have said in the amendment is
against any comments just a chat we have
one person voted for the amendment no
one voted against one up sensor which is
councillor Shipman and now we have been
recorded
so we are now moving to the vote and I
want to take a recorded vote
I will call out your name right we
should now move to recorded votes when I
call out your name please indicate
clearly rather than you wish to vote for
or against the web hope you wish to have
stayed based on the previous counselor
and click counselor Armitage Oh
counselor vodka Oh counselor bearing for
counselor business or counselor bone
that's ghost avoiding G coz of the foam
pads counselor clothed counsel the
Cornwell full house the Cupit council
the Dale or counselor Elliot's counselor
Evans counselor Angelique foster
counselor and posture or counselor Gomez
rename or cancel the hall or counselor
Hancock or cancel the hearthstone or
counselor detail or counselor homes
counselor today counsel hunt or a little
cheese in full council of Jones
Chancellor Kenya for counselor Carrie
Paul councilor Lewis for counselor
Liggett pull cancel the lily that's you
oh yeah more like against the parking or
as the Pickering or cancel the Pops
Oh counselor Powell Oh counselor Rita
Oh cancel the ring week for canceled the
roof counselor revs for cancel the roof
may I invite our counsel to descend
represent the second motion please
Thank You Caroline the subject's
confirmation I have that I'm pleased as
was already said that this is actually
considering obviously every person in
this room I'm sure you've run new houses
or late start parking around the
district
I'm not gonna mix with emotion there's
no point hopefully we get as much
support on this one as we did the last
certain I think we're all saying the
same thing true that there is a problem
initiate the strategic review so I move
this was a debate
does anyone else want to say anything
Thank You Jen thank you to Hancock for
bringing this motion forward as counsel
that literally explained at the
beginning of the meeting the
conservative group supports the
principle of this motion as you said
it's an issue that's raised with all
those I'm sure all that on the doorsteps
during the election campaign and have it
probably week in week out from residents
it's an issue which I'm where the the
council's asset management group already
considers quite regularly
I think it's paid and simple that our
road layouts and parking provisions were
designed for the number of cars that we
have family nowadays so there is a
problem not just in this area but across
the country and there's several
locations around the district where we
have grass verges or wide verges and
present layouts where we're seeing an
absolutely decimated by cars and making
please you look very untidy so I think
the the call to action the need to do
something about this and look at what
our options aren't very much welcome the
only thing that we would say is that
I've seen too many times strategy
reviews now not actually end up anywhere
so the only that I would like to propose
that we amend is to change strategy for
scrutiny review thereby we get a
definite reporting mechanism back to the
council and obviously all parties can
then be involved in that discussion
around options and I just think that
would be a slightly better way of
ensuring that it comes back we can have
that breakfast fishermen and involve all
councillors who were all affected by it
so that would be like the post amendment
to that
I second that parolee is that's for
reasons that catch the devil speaking on
the amendment to get it
I'm sympathetic to the review I think we
were going to support it the resolution
it's done through our words are amending
so I don't know how this fits in
Constitution me we're way if we can just
go three listen listenmi out and see if
we can work it out I was just going to
take out everything after district in
the fact the prioritizing areas where
concerns have been raised by residents
in my head brings them the Chaldees get
the gay and I don't think that's right
here are every asset management bill
there's been something called regarding
party the last estimate and it was only
an estimate to resolve all the parking
issues in North Eastham issue he talking
over two million pound that was an
estimate because every estate has got
problems with parking that's a lot of
kitchens and bathrooms that's a lot of
rooms and windows so a strategic reveals
fine very discreet scrutiny she's fine
but I think at the end of it it should
be where the demand is the greatest not
where somebody shouting the loudest so I
don't know if you can fit that into your
amendment Alex are you with me on that
so I don't have to go through it twice
if you don't know I'm conscious the
council they all have the last word on
the event so I'm sure that council
they'll make agreed to with except a
friendly amendment to the amendment just
wanted to make a comment about council
Hancock you mentioned that our
conversation a couple of weeks ago and
at that point you were offered to
withdraw the motion because this is an
annual council meeting we talked all
about that and that this really should
be a civic ceremony rather than an event
probably
we are where we are at the time you have
agreed to withdraw it and it pending the
fact that from all sides every single
council in this room for elected members
will know of parking difficulties in the
ward day represent week every single one
have that every single one of us so I'm
sure we get cross-party support the fact
that counsel bail is already outlined
some of the work that's already been to
be gone and the fact in my announcement
today I've said that the parking review
is essential going forward and officers
need to prepare information that will go
before scrutiny and it could go scrutiny
committee the community's one first of
all and overlap in another scrutiny
committee which is about assets in the
district so there's work to be done in
actually looking at that more closely
with the things that you said councillor
Barca of course we don't want it to be
easily shell flounders gets most it's
about what's fair and equitable across
the district I think that's a sensible
way I'm going forward then I'm
disappointed Council on handcuffing you
mentioned the the fact about the
withdrawal motion because you've said I
didn't get back to you I didn't expect
you thinking I was going to get back to
you because what we said out there was a
gentlemen's agreement obviously
agreement so communication is important
to talk about these things from around
the district
considering the concerns raised by
residents and exploring all possible
solutions does that does that
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
however even a recent Estrella this is
no guarantee that today's meeting would
actually be live screams rather than
merely recorder without any confirmation
us to an intended use and so despite
being us to withdraw our motion for
today
we were able to obtain the independent
variable a shoe that made is comfortable
but this council has registered dr.
Collison we could make it fully
transparent and fully accountable to the
most important piece of all those in
actually clusters here and I know that
it's being touched on and earlier and
hopefully that this will go forward we
decided that to counter those two was
too important to be left to the whims of
the council as to when or where the
meeting should be available to the wider
public and that's a formal resolution be
approved by council was the only way to
guarantee a move which is in the public
interest and the a few minutes ago given
the account to the planning committee
session on the puzzle of alcohol drug
development which provides bank
Challenge we have a duty to be
accountable okay
and only by throwing off and the council
practices to a greater level of scrutiny
can we accomplish that I think I also
need to work but there's a lot of
members in that contra sound they do sit
behind closed doors and they do use
computers it would be lovely if they had
access to our council members to be
given a choice even that we have cameras
present today I'm sure the conservative
group will have absolutely no problem in
supporting this motion and ensuring that
it becomes enshrined as a natural cause
this council operation could I have a
seconder please I'll second this motion
I've been recording these reasons for a
while now and they do get regular people
watching them it's a shame that the fact
that this one's not live stream what I'm
sure Martin would be happy to implement
this after this motion of the pluses
today so yeah hopefully the organ
support is a step in the right direction
I think a lot of people will be very
happy that they've got access to this
meeting live streamed and not just video
recorded puts us crucial as more and
more people and looking at live stream
they're going forward so thank you
anyone else wishing to speak thank you
for this motion and I think that every
counselor in the chamber will agree with
the points and sentiments that you've
raised within it it's always been the
conservative grits policy to increase
transparency and accessibility and
scrutiny of all meetings in this council
as we regularly phrase this in previous
meetings inside and outside this chamber
and the emotions and panels as well and
it's demonstrated already as an
administration through today's recording
which I'm informed is being
live-streamed and I think there's eight
people currently watching on YouTube so
who yep I do want to the place in view
about the fact that we have got a live
streaming and to do that I want to
propose a small amendment to the mention
can we change the and then can we also
change the bottom just to ensure that
that will be rolled out and tour
meetings as relevant in the future
yes there just to it so also though
we've got new members across this labor
group I want to make it clear that we
always supported open and transparency
and we support it going forward so just
to know what the rights from the labor
group we support opening transparency or
support I must have my only concern I
remember because that kinda goes against
the spirit of what we're saying
making everything
I welcome obviously they do the
reactions from both both groups in the
chamber I find a little bit of them as
much as supportive on play before before
the council before but I accept
obviously we've got you can make up to
the council now so it's not I was not
before but rather basically future so
thank you both sides feel supportable by
Andersen and welcome to developments for
jingles because work back with and start
councillor Hancock I understand what
you're saying you want to hold approach
to actual filming of meetings but they
point to this amendment is so that we
can actually look at what types of
meetings need to be filmed or can't with
government so for example a taxi
licensing committee which actually deals
with individuals we have to think about
data protection reasons and so on so
there's a whole reason I know you're
trying to capture that in there but this
review actually looks at things in the
first instance as I said already we've
given a commitment in my speech at the
outset of this meeting to actually live
stream this is our very first meeting
we've only been in control for two weeks
and already we have a camera now
live-streaming and this was an
indication that I gave to you some time
ago
and that's why I'm surprised you once
again that Council wind is mentioning
the withdrawal of the motion the reason
for the asking of the withdrawals this
is a civic occasion and then you've not
done council long enough to understand
the difference between a business
meeting an acidic occasion and I know
it's slightly different on the Monday on
this activity but it's a civic occasion
and it could have just waited and have
more common conversations around this
better communication we could have all
got to a point where we could have
actually talked about where we go from
here the only thing to put all these
motions in all in one go that's up to
you I am disappointed by the comments
about whims of the council I think
that's a really unfortunate phrase that
you can use their counseling because
that's actually potentially of an insult
to every single member who sits here
because we represent those people who
actually puts us into our office and
those people expect us to represent them
at meetings take votes knowing that we
have all the information to hand and
actually think about what we're doing
not just act on wind that is potentially
an insult and I'm sorry that you have to
say that but I do agree with all the
comments that you actually made out
today I believe that the planning
committee
a film and I believe is not some other
committees that should be filled
therefore I think it's important that we
actually only need a review now judge
you see where we go from here today
first of all counsel it's a step let's
see what happens
- the council knows well notes Mitka
mean the leadership team they trainees
mine actually
whereas with old commits the council to
livestream and he's taking a livestream
way squinting you to April just don't
hate people watching it well actually on
my phone to my own councillor page it's
got eight people in it
now you stream it to YouTube and then
they stream it to social media where all
of the users and people will interrupt
with the council of my heart so we need
to get that I think that links not even
on with the council social media so if
you talk about it being my freedom but
the reality is no one on social media
that's following this council is
watching that video and that to me is
why we should have the same resolves and
not know because I know if I'm wrong for
it allows the use of team to just pull
it wherever it wants in the dark corners
at website are not actually in front of
people which is the spirit of the motion
just like to say Council on plot this
for groups now on this council and I'll
be supporting this motion share personal
explanation under which of the council
procedure rules he wishes to speak just
to go back to councilor Bacchus comments
which I mean yes I have been on this
council as long as many about this but
this is the first time I think the call
is not for business meeting on the same
day as a civic Saturday and I think
that's a dangerous precedent but also
about the contest
if I could just for the purpose of
clarity there in effect previously there
has been a civic meeting then a business
meeting the realities we have had the
same all those being on one agenda so
the amounts of business that's being
tabled at this meeting has been the same
as it has in previous years but not with
two separate agendas because under the
Civic meeting you have the review of the
Constitution you have have the scheme of
delegation so the realities things are
not a difference in practice they just
appear different on paper I just want to
say I'm disappointed by the comments of
councilor ship and in terms of the
commitment to the motion and the
commitments of this council as myself
and councilor factor and all the
speakers call this making board the
indicators were quite clearly committed
to my Australian meetings going forwards
as judged by today recording and live
streaming of the meetings during our
currently and we made this commitment
everything else artifact is only a
speech and in our speeches today on a
live-streaming that's recorded for
posterity as well and so I would also
say that in terms of the you rightly
raise the point of getting the message
out there and encouraging people to
acute in and so within the review the
evaluation that can be considered about
how we spread that message and get
people sort of tuna and tuning and take
past and have 4x8 so I was linking and
then
[Music]
you've changed the motion so the motion
on the floor now is the motion as
amended if there are no further speakers
you move to the vote to accept that has
been the one for the record
Thank You chair the council disappointed
is one independent person to assist with
member complaints and certain employment
issues relations offices there have
always been two independent persons
although there was such a minimum is
actually one and having two seems to
work well in terms of resilience as
previously reported one of the council's
existing independent persons did not
wish to extend his appointment
accordingly a recruitment process was
undertaken and five people were
interviewed mr. Graham Hudson was
collected at interview and the
recommendation on page two of the report
is asked
[Music]
you